>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
MORE REACTION TO OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
THE AUTHOR OF THE BEST
SELLING BOOK TRUMPED UP
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
ENDANGERS DEMOCRACY.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ AND FORMER
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA, JOE
DIGENOVA, TWO OF THE
SMARTEST LAWYERS IN THE
COUNTRY.
LAST NIGHT I GOT INCREDIBLE
REACTION TO YOUR COMMENTS.
COLLUSION IS NOT A CRIME.
BUT WE GO FROM COLLUSION TO
OBJECT DESTRUCTION TO THE
BANK RECORDS.
HE IS NOT A TARGET.
THE MEDIA IS HE IS NOT A
TARGET BUT STILL IN
JEOPARDY.
THERE IS NO WINNING HERE.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU IF
AFTER A YEAR OF VERY
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION AND
GOING AFTER ALL THE
LOW-HANGING FRUIT AND
GETTING PEOPLE NOT ONLY TO
SING BUT SOME OF THEM EVEN
PERHAPS TO COMPOSE, IF THEY
COULDN'T HAVE SHIFTED HIM
FROM A SUBJECT TO A TARGET
THERE IS NOTHING THERE.
>> Sean: ARE THEY HOPING?
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE
HOPING.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT NOW
THEY ARE GOING INTO VERY
WEAK ISSUES.
COLLUSION.
I CHALLENGE MUELLER TO TELL
ME WHAT STATUTE IS VIOLATED
BY COLLUSION THERE IS A MEMO
NOW BY ROSENSTEIN
AUTHORIZING HIM TO
INVESTIGATE COLLUSION WITH
THE RUSSIANS BY MANAFORT.
BUT YOU CAN'T INVESTIGATE
SINS.
CAN YOU ONLY INVESTIGATE
FEDERAL CRIMES.
AND THERE IS NO SUCH FEDERAL
CRIME COLLUSION.
>> Sean: HOW DO THEY NOT
KNOW THAT.
>> THEY NO IT, BUT THEY HOPE
THAT BY INVESTIGATING
COLLUSION THEY WILL GET
SOMEBODY TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE, TO COMMIT PERJURY,
TO COMMIT ONE OF THESE OTHER
PEFERL CRIMES AS THEY ALWAYS
SAY IT'S IN THE COVERUP.
BUT IT'S NOT THE COVERUP.
IT'S THAT PROSECUTORS INDUCE
COVERUPS WHICH IS WHY
INNOCENT PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE
TESTIFYING UNLESS THEY
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO BECAUSE
YOU CAN BE INDICTED FOR
PERJURY EVEN IF YOU TELL THE
TRUTH.
IF YOU SAY SOMETHING THAT
SOMEBODY ELSE SAYS
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Sean: THAT'S A
SPECTACULAR STATEMENT.
YOU COULD BE INDICTED FOR
PERJURY FOR TRUTH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IF PROSECUTOR CONTRADICTS
YOU.
YOU ARE INDICTED FOR PERJURY
EVEN THOUGH YOU TOLD THE
TRUTH.
>> Sean: I WILL GET BACK TO
THAT QUESTION IN JUST A
SECOND.
LET ME GO TO JOE DEGENERAL.
HAVE A ROD ROSENSTEIN ISSUES
THIS LETTER TO MUELLER,
ALLOWING HIM TO GO AFTER
PAUL MANAFORT THE WAY HE
DID, THE WEEK AFTER THEY DID
THE RATE.
WHY DO I THINK THE ORDER OF
THAT LEGALLY NEEDS TO BE
REVERSED?
>> WELL, LET'S SAY, THIS
FIRST OF ALL, ABOUT ROD
ROSENSTEIN, HIS CONDUCT FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THIS HAS
BEEN A DISGRACE LEGALLY AND
EVERY OTHER WAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS TRULY TOO BAD THAT HE
CANNOT BE FIRED.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NEVER BEEN
A TARGET.
THE FACT THAT HE HAS BEEN
RECENTLY NOTIFIED THAT HE IS
THE SUBJECT MEANS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
HE IS NOT EVEN A SUBJECT.
HE IS A WITNESS.
A SUBJECT IS A PERSON
HESITATE CONDUCT IS WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THE GRAND
JURY'S INVESTIGATION.
WHAT'S THE HELL DOES THAT
MEAN?
THAT MEANS THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON HIM.
THERE HAVE BEEN 19 CRIMINAL
CASES.
NOT ONE PIECE OF EVIDENCE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND NOW WE ARE TOLD THAT
MUELLER WANTS TO INTERVIEW
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WHO KNOWS NOTHING.
WHO HAS BEEN A WITNESS TO
NOTHING.
WHO IS NOT A TARGET OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW IS
CONDUCT BY TWO PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, ROBERT MUELLER
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN THAT IS
UNETHICAL, UNPROFESSIONAL,
AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT AND
IS UNDERMINING EQUAL
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
>> Sean: THERE IS NO DOUBT.
>> BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ROD ROSENSTEIN
SINGLE-HANDEDLY HAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES 16 MONTHS OF HIS
PRESIDENCY BY INCOMPETENCE.
YOU KNOW WHY ROD ROSENSTEIN
APPOINTED MUELLER?
HE DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE THE
TOUGH DECISIONS YOU WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE IF YOU WERE
SUPERVISING A CASE BEING RUN
BY A UNITED STATES ATTORNEY
LIKE HUBER.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS A COWARD.
HE IS A DISGRACE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT'S A SHAME.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T FIRE HIM.
>> IT'S A SHAME THE
PRESIDENT CANNOT FIRE HIM
BECAUSE OF THE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES.
>> THEY CAN'T FIRE HIM.
IT'S AMAZING HE HASN'T BEEN
RECUSED.
>> CORRECT.
>> HE IS THE MAIN WITNESS ON
WHETHER OR NOT COLLUSION OR
WHETHER OR NOT -- I'M SORRY,
WHETHER OR NOT OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE OCCURRED WITH THE
FIRING OF COMEY.
>> Sean: DOESN'T THE
PRESIDENT HAVE ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO FIRE ANYBODY.
>> HE DOES.
POLITICALLY HAVE THERE IS A
RIGHT TO DO IT AND IT BEING
RIGHT TO DO IT.
COMMENT ON ONE THING JOE HAS
SAID.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THEY
HAVE DEPRIVED THE RIGHT OF
THE PRESIDENT TO GOVERN.
THE REPUBLICANS DID THE SAME
THING TO CLINTON.
WHEN THEY IMPEACHED HIM.
>> Sean: SIX YEARS INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY.
>> WELL, STILL, THEY MADE A
MISTAKE AND THEY PAID A
HEAVY CONSEQUENCE FOR IT I
THINK THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
PAY A HEAVY COST IF THEY
MADE THE SAME MISTAKE.
TRYING TO IMPEACH WITHOUT
BEING ABLE TO REMOVE.